it's the first person sentenced in that
massive College Admission scandal will
spend no time in prison a federal judge
sentenced former Stanford sailing coach
John van d'amour to one day behind bars
but he gets credit for time served Don
Dahler is outside federal court in
Boston Don this seems like a surprise is
there any other punishment yes well
along with a $10,000 fine van d'amour
will serve two years of supervised
release and that includes six months of
home confinement with electronic
monitoring still that is far less than
the 13 months in prison prosecutors were
asking for this case for me was about
trying to do what I thought was right
for the team former Stanford sailing
coach John van d'amour may be spared
from prison but he says he'll carry the
weight of his actions for the rest of
his life
I have brought a cloud over Stanford and
for that I am deeply deeply ashamed
Vanda Moore admitted to taking more than
$600,000 from admitted mastermind Rick
Singer to get the children of wealthy
parents into Stanford as sailing
recruits but his attorneys argued he
never pocketed the money instead using
it for sailing uniforms and equipment
and they pointed out that no student was
admitted because of his help Bizzy got
two young kids married trying to you
know do well at his job and I think he
never stopped to reflect on this
relationship he had with singer until
you have FBI agents sitting in your
living room that's a wake-up call yeah
it is in his only sit-down interview
Vanda mores attorney Robert Fisher
explained how his clients relationship
with singer developed over two years
where it started with Rick singer saying
having me I have some recruits that
could be helpful to you and here's a
donation to the program it then morphed
slowly over time into yeah I have a
recruit maybe not a great sailor but I
can get you a big donation the program
Vanda Moore is one of 50 people charged
in the 25 million-dollar scheme actress
Felicity Huffman has pleaded guilty
Lorie Lachlan and her husband are still
fighting the charges legal analyst Tony
Fuller should the other defendants be
celebrating his sentence
I don't know that did they'd be
celebrating it every sentence with each
individual will be different and each
there's
all different judges who have different
judicial temperaments and different
things that they will take into account
Stanford says it sees the money it
received from singer scam as tainted and
it plans to redirect those funds
prosecutors say they will continue to
seek meaningful penalties in these cases
now next month the man whom singer
described as a great test taker mark
Radel it's his time to be sentenced
Anthony all right Don Dahler Thank You
Don